- Welcome to "The Kelly Clarkson Show."
Now as you can see, Kelly's
not in the studio today.
Y'all supposed to say, "Aw."
- [Audience] Aw.
- Yeah, yeah.
But this is a very special show.
It's gonna be "The Best
Man: The Final Chapters"
takeover show.
(audience cheers and applauds)
I got the whole cast back
there ready to have some fun.
Now, this is a franchise
that I've been a part of
for a very long time now.
So I'm really excited
that it's coming back
as a series on Peacock
starting December 22nd.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Let me hear y'all say December 22nd.
- [Audience] December 22nd.
- That's right, that's right.
But before we get to my co-stars,
you know, I'm in a little
mood for some music.
Y'all ready for some music?
- [Audience] Yeah.
- All right, so here's
Kelly and her band Y'all
with the Kellyoke Encore performance
of one of my favorite gym
songs, "Finesse" by Bruno Mars.
(audience cheers and applauds)
(upbeat funky music)
♪ Ooh, don't we look good together ♪
♪ There's a reason why they
watch all night long, hey ♪
♪ Yeah, I know we'll turn heads forever ♪
♪ So tonight I'm gonna show you off ♪
♪ When I'm walkin' with you ♪
♪ I think the whole room change ♪
♪ I watch the whole room come here ♪
♪ Yeah, that's what you do ♪
♪ Baby, that's what you do ♪
♪ My baby, don't play ♪
♪ No ♪
♪ Blame it on my confidence ♪
♪ Oh, blame it on your measurements ♪
♪ Shut that shit down on sight ♪
♪ Hey, that's right ♪
♪ We out here drippin' in finesse ♪
♪ It don't make no sense ♪
♪ Out here drippin' in finesse ♪
♪ You know it, you know it ♪
♪ We out here drippin' in finesse ♪
♪ It don't make no sense ♪
♪ Out here drippin' in finesse ♪
♪ You know it, you know ♪
♪ Fellas grab your ladies
if your lady's fine ♪
♪ Tell her she the one ♪
♪ She the one for life ♪
♪ Ladies grab your fellas
and let's do this right ♪
♪ If you're one like me and mine ♪
♪ Oh, we're drippin' in finesse ♪
♪ It don't make no sense ♪
♪ Out here drippin' in finesse ♪
♪ You know it, you know ♪
♪ We out here drippin' in finesse ♪
♪ It don't make no sense ♪
♪ Out here drippin' in finesse ♪
♪ You know it, you know it ♪
(audience cheers and applauds)
- Give it up for them. Come on.
- Come on, one more time
for Kelly and her band, Y'all.
Come on.
(audience cheers and applauds)